This morning, my husband told me to be ready by four PM
since he was taking me on a date.
During my pregnancy, all I craved was raw fish,
and I tried having it as little as possible.
So now that I can have it again,
he knew that he had to take me here.
I usually look at the menu before I even get to the restaurant,
so I knew exactly what I wanted.
But lucky had a little look through,
and we started off with a mocktail for me and a ginger beer for him.
Then had to order some shishito peppers.
We do that every restaurant.
And some of the yellow tail sashimi.
I also got crispy rice, tuna,
and these wagyu. Little tacos are one of our favorite things to get,
and I don't know what it is,
but I prefer Nobu appetizers over the main dishes.
After we made our way through those,
we ordered our mains before it was time to order my second mocktail.
I always tell the waiter
to surprise me with whatever they think I would like,
and it usually works out.
Then we moved on to getting a second plate of the shishito peppers,
and then our main dishes arrived.
Lucky got some steak dish while I got the black miso con.
Steak was so good and the cod was so flaky it just fell apart.
I also got two sides of rice with that.
Couldn't stop ordering sides.
We Ended up having over 25 of these tacos
and kept all the other sides coming.
Time they would run out,
and I moved on to my third mocktail of the night,
and I was so stuffed at this point.
So lucky paid and we left to find something sweet.
I always need something sweet after having dinner,
so I found this soft serve place and got myself a vanilla soft serve.
This was actually really, really good.
We ended up pumping some gas,
and it was getting so cold so quick.
So lucky got me a blanket from the gas station to bundle up in
before we made our way down to the beach to catch the sunset.
We haven't been in a while,
but every time we go, it's so magical.
And that's where we ended our night.